moi j'avais surprise qu'on s'arrête
beaucoup sur le mot revient sion s'était
les manifestations de la semaine mais
martial compose aussi rédac avec moi sur
l' ordonnance que vous citez de jouer 9
avril 2017
ça concerne toutes les villes de
barcelone ça dépasse le mans il ya trois
ans déjà il ya eu de grosses
manifestations à rouen où pareil on
avait enlevé les forains du centre-ville
pour les mettre à l'extérieur donc c'est
quelque chose qui existe depuis
plusieurs années de nombreuses années il
ya une charte qui a été signé en 2001
avec un ministère de la culture
déjà pourrait éviter ça moi ce que nos
personnes la respecte je sais que
personne ne respecte ce que je ne
comprends pas pourquoi aujourd'hui
vous dites que vous allez à l'elysée
vous le dites que vous allez
régulièrement
pourquoi est ce qu'on ne vous entend pas
pourquoi ce que ça n'évolue pas et
pourquoi est-ce qu'on en est un dont on
expansion nous écoute mais on nous
entend pas on nous dit avec un truc tu
mens amenez vos propositions et ça fait
vingt mois que ça dure
nous ça fait un mois que ça dure et
pendant ce temps là on appris que la
réglementation
non mais avant c'était autre chose le
problème de développer de delta de
l'association c'est un problème
particulier qui vous il faut des
dialogues avec les maires
il ya un problème national en ce moment
alors il ya une loi qui va éteindre le
monde forain donc faut pas s'étonner sam
s'excite alors qu'il avait cette idée
juste de leur avenir
j'ai vivement m les excite dirimant
maison vu que dans la télé date se nomme
harcèlement on les écoute
jb c'est qu'on est là pour ça jamie benn
et physiquement c'est que
malheureusement la violence fait qu'on
en parle aujourd'hui sinon on serait pas
en train de débattre et tient va être
quoi faire avancer sa quille et risque
est dramatique et dramatique
l'impression qu'en france que rien
n'avance
lorsqu'on cherche un négociant 80 tables
qu'on fait des grèves on en arrive à des
situations assez dramatique mais on se
plaint du matin au soir que le
centre-ville moeurs qui n'a pas
d'activité
on ramène à la fête foraine qui reste
quelque chose de populaire marquant
jamais de mes enfants faire la pêche aux
canards chez dc bidon mais sont contents
ils sont heureux c'est super bien même
si servi dont j'étais champion deux
heures de pêche aux canards 2018 2019
c'est une petite activité mais on voit
bien qu'ils sont très heureux
alors c'est vrai que en ile-de-france on
l'a dit ce talent dans la parc astérix
meilleurs ils ont droit de s'amuser en
centre-ville pourquoi est ce qu'ils
devraient faire plus
j'ai exactement alors le panaf est à la
fois à la phase pénale à la fête foraine
on vient avec nos moyens si tu as 10
euros bon match ils dépensent 10 06 et
un public super un peu plus mais ce
qu'on oublie c'est que quand on vous
exporte en dehors du centre-ville
et ben si votre chiffre d'affaires
diminue et que vous êtes mec mettre la
clé sous la porte et que ces gens là
faut pas croire ils ont des familles
mais c'est ça les enfants sur des gens à
nourrir quelques mois je les vois en
visite je vais aussi à la fête foraine
dans le 12e arrondissement visite c'est
des gens qui cherchent à vivre comme les
autres
et si derrière moi demain j'avais
affaire dutroux ouais en visite à
domicile et je vais voir les forains
dans le xiième ça m'est arrivé
vous avez une urgence dans un bateau
pirate non mais c'est rigolo mais ça
arrive à très fort mais je me mets à
leur place
si demain matin on menaçait mon emploi
et que je ne pourrai plus à manger mes
enfants est-ce que je ne réagirai pas
pareil à la question et rien ne manquait
à nouveau répondre à la question des
violences mais de la légitime colère
c'est la même chose que pour les jeunes
c'est des gens qui font pas la manche
ils n'ont pas ce qu'on leur fasse le
mode ils veulent juste travailler c'est
des gens qui prennent des crédits qui
s'endettent pendant longtemps et dans le
piège d'un accord il reste dans le pirlo
répond matinée donc ce n'est pas
seulement un dialogue entre la mairie et
les forains qu'on a entendu des
habitants du centre-ville qui n'y sont
pas favorables
moi je suis quand même pour écouter ce
que dit la population mais nord l'a
écoutée chez pas il ya pas un sondage
alors allé il ya des gens qui nous
attendait quand on doit mcdonald's sur
la vie des gens de mer à jamais hors de
cause la question
d'après ce qu'on a entendu en tout cas
une partie des gens je sais pas s'ils
sont majoritaires ou minoritaires je ne
dispose plus de jeu ne dispose pas de
sondages
à l'opposé vous avez pâte y sont opposés
à la présence à des forains en centre
ville
ensuite est-ce que vraiment on est
certain que la place des forains est au
centre-ville de moi j'en suis qui sera
toujours été comme ça a toujours été
comme ça alors qu'ils ont fait est ce
qu'on peut avoir
alexandre directeur alexandre employés
dans le secteur privé ancien habitant dû
mourir si la place des forains et elle
n'est pas forcément tout le temps au
centre ville d'alençon qui à 60 km du
mans c'est pas en centre ville c'est en
zone et ça fonctionne très bien à tour
c'est pas en centre ville
et ça fonctionne ailleurs et c'est
ensemble amis l'addition circassie
l'année foraine en france elle tient
auquel tient à au coeur des français
et elle tient au coeur des manceaux
également jean claude boulard quand en
2013 quand juste après avoir fait la
photo de la municipalité de son équipe
municipale
gagner la mairie vous savez ce qu'il a
fait juste après la photo on est allé
faire un tour de grande roue
voilà c'est con c'est symbolique c'est
idiot mais on tient justement à la
présence foraine en ville
malheureusement il ya deux problèmes
l'infrastructure et la sécurité la
sécurité on en a parlé et
l'infrastructure on l'a également évoqué
un million d'euros sur la zone du panama
du panorama pour l'aménager pour
permettre une présence
donc moi quand j'entends et quand je
vois j'ai vu les panneaux le mans
interdit au fort ah non vous pouviez
vous m les manceaux dans la poche s'il
n'y avait pas eu toutes ces dégradations
et s'étonnant monsieur il a rien de plus
je pense que 35 ans gisait dans la rue
du marais 'cela fait l'opération pendant
deux jours et puis les foreurs on et
offrir des énormément de tension
sexuelle avait déjà lui même